always great to see Chris Sims co-host a
pro football talk live with Mike Florio
and of course former NFL quarterback we
were just talking about quarterback tix
and Drew Brees has - he's the poster
child for like weird things to do prior
to the snap yes I mean after every throw
it slicked both hands shoulder twitch
pulled down New Jersey and the shoulder
pads but that's quarterbacks and that's
what makes him - it makes him him is he
has a process almost like every play
he's a machine
and that's why he's surgical at the
quarterback position
who else has ticks oh gosh Peyton
Manning used to have so many ticks Eli's
got ticks you ever see Eli after every
throw he throws he he kind of does like
a shoulder a little wiggle and then he
does it one more time it's a we all have
ticks even my father had ticks when I
watch back old games he used to clap his
hands after every throw whether it was
incomplete or that you know or complete
either way but it's you don't realize it
until you watch yourself a little what
do you remember from the combine the
thing I remember being stressed and out
of my element like man I got to go down
here and eat in a you know formal a big
gathering room right it's just there's
no time to yourself I remember that I
remember also yeah you know being
worried about my weight being worried
about my interviews and more than
anything I was just stressed out about
the 40 I mean it's do we have Chris Sims
40-point yeah who wants to go closest to
the hole or you do give me an over/under
on Chris Sims legendary quarterback of
Texas Oh dual-threat Chris you're like
what six five to 20 yeah I think I think
I measured it at six four and five
eighths and I was 220 - I think okay
let's go four point nine seconds for the
over/under of your 40-yard dash
did-did-did four nine four as he was the
originator of the run-pass option oh wow
I think we're right right on the
mason-dixon line right there I'm gonna
go under I'm gonna go under for nine
just under four point eight six am dan
we got hand-sized or eight six or eight
six week really that's pretty good I
thought it was for eight -
but that's alright fine whatever yes I
don't Wonderlic yeah
you and Ted Ginn jr. really that close
yes yes okay we got hands sighs I'm
gonna go
you give me over-under I'm going over
but I didn't hear you sighs Oh hand
sighs I know I'm over ten I just don't
know what I am exactly
okay the average NFL quarterbacks hand
size is about nine and three quarters at
the combine I don't know you remember
getting my hand measured at the combine
I remember getting it measured at the
Senior Bowl and at the Senior Bowl I
know I had the second biggest hand on
both teams there was a Dee tackle for
Miami so you only had one hand that was
bigger the other one what else do you
have 10.5 inches for your measurement
hand size and a half a with a second
highest of your season okay
who was number one if you know that's
all right don't worry it doesn't matter
okay now here's a tough one Chris yeah
the Wonderlic scores me I think I took
the Wonderlic twice right I took it once
illegally from a team which I can tell
you that team what do you mean you took
Italy I took it to a team gave it to me
illegally when I was at Texas like they
could they brought me into a room and
there okay we just want to talk to you
for a second it was a scout of a team
and then he threw the Wonderlic in front
of me so I know I'm that Wonderlic I got
a 27 I'm not gonna tell you the team
okay but in the combine and I think I
got a 23 how long - how often do you
think that happens a lot I think it's
well like if a if a scout has been
around for a while and has a
relationship with a college coach it's a
way of him getting a little bit of a
feel for a player before everybody else
does I think it goes on not like I say a
lot but occasionally how much did it
help you at least gave me what to expect
from the test I don't know what I got
the combat I think I got a 22 right Dan
Chris Simms who had the Wonderlic test
in advance got 22 out of 50 on the way
yeah yeah you know what I got a look you
got worse than you did when you because
I missed the first test I took I got
lucky with the vocab words that's really
what it was there was vocab words that I
said okay I know these minds right no
vocabulary words I don't know but what
do they have to do with between my New
Jersey education
we also had this with Sam Darnell we
wanted to know Pauly said because he's
got a big head
yes is he gonna have big hands well then
Peyton Manning would have the biggest
hands like history of the sport right
Wow
I had huge head I mean I'm more of a
long head if you could see I always
write it so long it's not a fat head
it's a long one but I had to get hell I
was had one of the biggest helmets on
the team always Pauly what do you have
the over-under on hand size for all
quarterbacks the average and combine
history is 9 and 5/8 inches who wants to
take over or under force and Arnold of
USC man why does fumble a lot it's gonna
be close this would be I'm interested to
hear this this is this is something
that's important I think for him I'm
gonna go under I'm gonna go under as
well just barely you're both right nine
and three inches okay if you're the
Cleveland Browns and Sam darn old right
now not throwing at the combo yeah yeah
no doesn't matter no it does not to me I
don't think you know I've spent the last
three days watching these quarterbacks
the top big five right and I've really
studied them so I feel like I got him
down and you know no no offense to Sam
Darnell he's a really good player and
he's got a lot of play making ability
but there's no way he deserves to be the
first pick of the draft or the fourth
pick of the draft or am i for my money
who does I think the best quarterback in
the draft is Lamar Jackson from
Louisville I mean I really yeah I know
you're looking at I didn't think I was
gonna be saying that two three days ago
when I started in on this I didn't I
started watching I went Josh Allen one
Baker Mayfield to then I watch Sam darn
old I watched Josh Rosen and then I
watched Lamar Jackson and I came away
and I write notes I got my notebook I
could show you everything I write and I
came away and I said Lamar Jackson is
the best quarterback in this draft for
me
he's the only one that has no questions
the only question you have about him is
you know can he take the beating and the
way he plays in the NFL but
decision-making throwing accuracy
accuracy to a degree but I would I would
argue there a little bit I mean he he
doesn't get a ton of easy throws he
throws the ball down the field
aggressively but why is it we question
his accuracy but not Josh Allen whose
completion percentage was lower than the
bar right I don't understand that either
I think there's a lot of things that are
being unfairly said about Lamar Jackson
Lamar Jackson's two out of all the guys
they all have one glaring question to me
and Lamar Jackson's the only one that
does not have a question I mean he's the
only guy that I look at and go it's
clean slate the decision-making is
pretty good okay yeah accuracy if you're
gonna be picky but he throws a lot of
aggressive down the field throw so
you're gonna miss throws
now the Josh Josh Allen thing he's ultra
talented maybe the strongest arm I've
ever seen and that's saying something
because Patrick mahomes came out last
year I don't think he can throw it as
far as Patrick mahomes but if you ask
him to throw it thirty yards on a line I
think he can throw it harder than
anybody I've ever seen but yes he's a
little more raw than I expected watching
on film the ball he can lose control the
ball a little at times but I would also
say this to you Dan Patrick he plays in
Wyoming the team around him stinks I
watched three games and cut-ups and I
can tell you there wasn't five people
open in the three games and I saw the
Oregon game right so it was tough
sledding and I would also say he was
under more pressure than any of the
other quarterbacks in this
I mean combined if you add them all
together if he threw a hundred passes he
got hit on 90 of them so you that's why
it's a hard evaluation too so I don't
look at the completion percentage
because it's not an offense that lends
itself to completion percentage I
watched three games I think I saw two
screen passes where all the other
quarterbacks got to throw 810 screen
passes a game make their completion
percentage look good so he's got
big-time Talent - I have a few questions
certainly yeah okay so you talked about
Josh Allen with his question or
questions like Marv Jackson and by the
way yeah I've been all saying all along
the more Jackson's a first-round draft
oh he's a first-round draft pick and I'm
telling you for me right now
he's the firt he is the best quarterback
for me I'm putting my stamp on it right
now he is the guy okay
Baker Mayfield yes his big question is
size it is it's an in sizes sizes a
skill in the NFL just like we were
talking off air Tom Brady his ability to
stand in the pocket people around him
can't step into a throw because he's a
big long man he can throw a 30-yard out
route and and not have to be in perfect
technique form because he's a big man
Mayfield if I had to rank him okay I'll
just give you my rankings right off here
it'd be Lamar won I would go Alan - I
would go Mayfield three darnell Dan
Rosen are really close I'm gonna go darn
'old for just because of athleticism and
rows in five but getting back to
Mayfield I love Mayfield he's
awesome I mean he's a great thrower the
football he's a really good athlete the
offense and the big 12 style of play
lends to benefit him because it's wide
open and he could step up into big
passing lanes he doesn't necessarily
have to see over people but there are
things that are concerning to me in
games like Georgia and the semi-final in
that second half they did they played
man cover they got a good feel for what
they were exactly right wanted to get do
on offense and then they basically said
to me it looked like they said let's not
over rush stay in your lanes and just
see if we can kind of collapse the
pocket and that made the game hard on
Baker Mayfield still made a lot of good
plays don't get me wrong but that would
still be a glaring question for me going
forward
Josh Rosen's number one concerns the
athleticism
I mean lack of athleticism that is even
for this day and age in 2018 his his
body lack of muscle structure and just
quickness and ability to run and get
himself out of harm's way I think it's
part of the reason you've seen him get
hurt in two years is he is part of it so
that's the biggest thing for him he's a
great thrower the football like Josh
Rosen have you said okay Tom Brady can't
play this year and you need to pick one
of these guys to go fill in for a really
pro style offense and be surgical in
year one
Rosen's the guy he's ready to go right
away but Nord nor do I think he can
carry a team physically maybe like I
think a little more Jackson could or a
Baker may feel good maybe in the future
he needs a system and players around him
but if he has that his throwing and
decision-making is top-notch we're
talking to Chris Sims Pro Football Talk
live co-host with Mike Florio and of
course the former NFL quarterback yeah
trying to assess these quarterbacks and
then looking at the free agent market
here I've been on the the Kurt cousins
bandwagon to Minnesota here for almost
two weeks and it that Mets a smarter
landing I think than Denver would be
yeah John Elway came out and said hey
you know I don't know what we're gonna
do at number five and are they gonna
draft another quarterback these free
agent quarterbacks is AJ McCarron has
started yes he's he's in the
conversation I think he's earned his
right to at least compete for a starting
job and I really think at the end of the
day that's the one that makes sense in
my mind everyone I'm gonna even say
Denver to see I like Cleveland because
huge acts are now granted
might only be there one more year right
but you're reunited with a guy who likes
you tried to trade for you yes now let
me use those draft picks for something
other than a quarterback if I'm not sure
about drafting a quarter but sure I
don't have any problem with that I think
that's a smart thought process all the
way but this Denver go free agent
quarterback instead of trying to draft a
quarter this is the conundrum would you
like that big word was that under that
was that that Texas education right
there the the the I think the
predicament Denver's in is yeah Kirk
Cousins is probably gonna cost too much
money I don't expect them to go that
route do they bring an AJ McCarron in
they still have Paxton Lynch let's not
forget he's a first-round pick who
played good the last game of the year
when he played against Kansas City and
Patrick mahomes played he got kind of
overshadowed because mahomes made some
unreal throws in the game but Lynch
played well I gotta still think they
have a little hope for Paxton Lynch
that's why I go if you're bringing at AJ
McCarron you don't necessarily have to
overpay him you could pray him low level
starting type money and you can let them
compete to a degree now if they find
somebody in the draft then I would
expect them to go with whoever it is in
the draft especially being at the number
five pick but if Sheikh Juan Barkley is
the best player in the draft yes right
why wouldn't you take the best player if
you're Cleveland if they have oh yeah
I'm not I'm not against that I'm not but
at the same time he helps you right away
they have to address the quarterback
situation I want to get AJ McCarron
right okay if I'm not sold on any of
these quarterbacks I get him right and I
wait for the guy that we really need
here yeah but say Quan Barkley helps me
right away
yes Minka Fitzpatrick helps you ride
right away yeah and that's what
Cleveland needs yes he'll be let's wait
I hate we got our quarterback of the
future well what about now I know I know
and it's always been that way with
Cleveland so that here's another thing I
want to ask you yeah any of these
quarterbacks if we looked in the
previous drafts would they be taken
higher than Jameis Winston Marcus
Mariota or Carson Wentz and Jared Goff
now granted we know what lense is turned
into right but grade wise anybody higher
than those quarterbacks in preview yeah
I mean I thought Wentz was a star from
day one I mean I mean that's why this
year's interesting
because I do think there's legitimately
debate like to me there was no debate
last year I thought my Holmes was the
guy I thought Watson and true Brisky
were all really good legit but I thought
my Holmes is the guy
yes great wise I think I think you could
put a number of these guys above Jared
Goff in my opinion you know I don't you
put Lamar Jackson over Jared go I would
yes I would take him all day seven days
of the week 365 for hours do this you
know you're saying at the time when golf
was coming out yeah Mariota when he was
coming out right I think Lamar Jackson
I'm I was ultra impressed with Lamar
Jackson now I don't know what he's gonna
be like in the classroom and all that
I've met him and I've been around him
for about 30 minutes and he's a quiet
kid who I enjoyed being around a lot
like deshaun Watson so they're not gonna
come in the room and controlled the room
and be like mr. Johnny charismatic and
and just you know oh he cares man
yes speaking of him would you let me
take a break I want to ask you right if
you were GM or coach would you bring in
Johnny Manziel as a backup quarterback
so we'll continue with Chris Sims after
this on the Dan Patrick show before the
break I asked you if you're an NFL GM or
coach and you got Johnny Manziel out
there cuz he says hey I'll be on the
scout team I'll play for free cuz he
finally realized hey you know what your
15 minutes are up and nobody cares about
exactly right and he wants to be
relevant would you bring him in as a
backup quarterback no I would not I
would I would force I recognize Johnny
manziel's Talent I've met him a few
times and I do like Johnny Manziel the
guy he was obviously a little immature
and had some confusion in his life but I
would make him have to prove to me he's
back on the straight and narrow by going
to the Canadian Football League first
like he's got to pay his penance a
little bit I gotta see him for a year
first of all just playing game I need to
see him play the game he's gonna go to
meeting show up on time do all those
things first to go okay you've shown me
some evidence that you're actually ready
instead of you just telling me and
talking about it and I would add this to
a den you know as a guy who got hurt
with a career altering injury and it
took me basically two years to get
healthy it's really hard to come back
and play the game when you've missed not
only one year
but two years its quarterback positions
the hardest position in all of sports to
practice because there's nothing that
can emulate are the real game when it's
80,000 fans and all the sudden 280 pound
guys are legitimately trying to rip off
your head and that to me is a big reason
also why I'd like to see him go play up
and commit Canada for at least a year
yeah and he's been so good at biessing
people exactly and so he can be doing
that to you now hey trust me I'm coming
in and you know I'm gonna be the good
guy and right he's got a starters
attitude but backup quarterback talents
right now maybe at best right then I'd
have to see more Bill Polian who I've
always said has forgotten more football
than I know but I think he may have
forgotten his wits with this yeah and
when he's talking about what Nick Foles
would cost you if he wanted if you
called the Eagles you have to offer two
first-round and two second-round picks
you're right what am I missing on this
with Nick Foles well I mean that's
that's pretty insane asking price I mean
we're talking about the greatest trade
price in the history of the NFL for a
guy like Nick Foles who six weeks ago
everybody was telling me we should bench
him for Nate Sud felt okay or he was
released by the Kansas City Chiefs or
you know I mean didn't work well with
the st. Louis Rams whatever they worth
what he's worth to me it's gonna depend
on what that team that's desperate to
need a quarterback let's say Arizona
yeah Arizona I don't think you're gonna
be able to get a first-round pick I
think you could get like a second round
second round
maybe another throw in pick at some
point like a 2019 fifth round pick to go
a long way that are six around maybe if
they're desperate but I don't think
you're gonna be able to ask for much
more than that
again Nick Foles was a he played great
in the Superbowl but let's not forget
that that was one of the worst defenses
in football without one of their best
players on the field I am still a
believer that have Malcom Butler's
playing in that game I'd like to say
that the Patriots win that game yes we
still don't know why Malcom Butler
didn't play No
I don't know either I don't we find out
everything eventually not what the
Patriots you know and they I mean crap I
work for them and I still can't find out
the full story if you had to ask my
opinion just piecing things together
I think there is some things that
happened within his hotel room and I
don't know this so I'm not this is
allegedly so no one comes out I'm
speculating okay I do think there was
some things that went on in his hotel
room that annoyed the team he was sick
didn't practice well he came there a day
late probably do you know he hasn't
agreed to their lowball contract terms
which annoys them as well and I think it
all ended into a well they tried to
trade him in the office exactly right
and then they disrespected him by
bringing Stephon Gilmore in and paying
him all this big-time money I mean
Malcolm Butler is in the conversation
for one of the 10 best corners in the
sport he definitely is and last year he
certainly was or 2016-2017 Lutz
borderline but he's still gonna get a
big payday from somebody are you is
there sort of a boot camp you go through
with the Patriots where they kind of
deprogram you is it something they
actually do or just if you're in there
it's sort of by proxy that you you just
fall in line and this is the Patriot Way
yeah it's by proxy because you realize
pretty quickly when you sit down whether
you're a coach or a player that you go
well they don't need me here to be
successful you so you know that that
takes away a lot of your ego right off
the bat you go okay I'm not the
difference here they're pretty good no
matter what and I think players realize
that and then you've heard the stories
Dan right like Belichick the way he
talks to Brady and team meetings things
like that that's gonna bring everybody
down to a level as well and Bill's gonna
set people straight to if they talk too
much I mean if you go out there and
you're given the State of the Union
address for the New England Patriots the
next day he's gonna call you out and go
who the heck made you the you know the
Speaker of the House here for the New
England Patriots just shut up and play
football I mean so you learn pretty
quick your role and that you're just
there to play football take orders and
be part of the team and I wonder about
that dynamic with Belichick and Brady
yeah that after a while you just get
tired of hearing it sure and Brady
probably wants to lay he you know you
put the flag down at the North Pole or
something you know that it got to the
point where he's like hey you know what
I'm on equal footing with you I'm the
greatest of all time I guess you're the
greatest of all time is there mutual
admiration because
I don't even know if it feels like
there's mutual admiration I think there
definitely is Bella checks never I don't
think Bella checks the type of guy a lot
like Parcells was in my day he's not
gonna tell you how good he really thinks
you are until your career is done I mean
he's just as part of his magic he's
probably gonna intentionally piss Tom
off at time but your dad just rented him
Michelle's would yell at your dad
because he couldn't yell at Elte right
right yes and that's you mean balichek
will do that with brady not this not
because he won't yell at other people
but he's gonna make Brady the example to
go look at him I can yell at Brady who's
certainly one of the greatest of all
time but how does Brady Tate I know he
wants to be great he's amazing at taking
it and Brady has got he's got a great
way about him people think I don't like
Tom Brady which drives me crazy why do
they think that because I think he's
guilty of deflate gate yeah which I
still do okay and then I say Aaron
Rodgers the greatest quarterback of all
time I say pay I say Tom Brady is number
three I'm so just I'm such a mean person
I say he's the third greatest
quarterbacks Rodgers the greatest of all
time
big but because of this I don't I've
never seen anybody that can do the
things Aaron Rodgers can do he is the
greatest one-man band in the history of
the school so the most talented
quarterback is not the greatest
quarterback well to me it is a comp
accomplishment it's a team thing too I
think that if if you put Aaron Rodgers
the leader of the team I know but you
know he can't do it all you know he
can't look at what Brady has been given
on offense there you mean the greatest
nation in history whose greatest they
want a Super Bowl without him yeah I get
that they went to the Super Bowl without
Edelman and they had Brady's awesome I'm
not trying to sit here and say bad
things about Brady
don't do that to be damned Patrick I
with you I understand all that I will
say this Brady is amazing what he's
doing now is unreal he's better now to
me than he was five years ago when I was
working there I mean I really do believe
that cuz he throws the ball down the
field better now but it's not sure she's
got better wide receiver no he does not
got Jordy Nelson right
that's the third Devante dirt no Levante
is the only one they're gonna probably
release Randall Cobb they're only been
paid because of Aaron Rodgers that's
what I would argue with you there
nobody is breaking down Stillman going
oh no if we don't double Jordy Nelson
were indeed
crap like nobody does that you know when
you played in New England you go damn
Gronkowski we need a doublet man oh man
Edelman we need to double not doubling
at all no you do you have to see we got
to give Adelman respect I think it was
great he's the man he really is he's got
an ultra ultra impressive skill set so
again Brady has been amazing he's made
it happen with makeshift guys I'm not
gonna argue there but I don't like that
necessarily too because he has also had
people like I said Gronkowski Randy Moss
Wes Welker Aaron Hernandez Ben Watson
who had a thousand-yard season in the
year 14 you know I mean Troy Brown was a
good player Deion Branch was a good
player so that's where I just get
annoyed buddy on branch left and then he
disobey D makes those guys Wes Welker
was nothing in Miami well yeah I mean
they they scattered them out and they
brought him there cuz they know they
have a great offense so you don't like
Brady you're such a jerk and then I know
you don't like Blake bortles well look
you started that that's your nuts I like
Tom Brady just to set that straight I
only have like four autographs in my
possession and Tom Brady's one of them
that's how highly I think of Tom Brady
he signed it for you no he didn't he's
not gonna sign it for me now I'm sure
okay okay so Blake bortles signs the
extension yes yeah first of all yes I
did I lead you to slaughter because you
told me something about bortles that
he's the seventieth the best quarterback
and then I brought it up on the show
right and then I see you with this Super
Bowl and you're like you know sort of
poking me a little bit a little man like
hey you know in trouble with Blake
mornings here I go you got yourself in
trouble with Blake board I definitely
did no I I'm still confident about that
statement are you better quarterback
than Blake bortles I mean right now no
I'm not gonna say right now I'm not
gonna be that district next year I mean
maybe you know towards the end of my
career I'd like to think certain oh yes
okay definitely
Jacksonville make a mistake well of
course they did in my opinion but they
were also backed into a corner one by
themselves and to by the team I mean
they did go to the AFC Championship game
right so that's tough to abandon ship on
any quarterback I don't care how poor he
is when you go ma'am we were that close
and really were the better team on the
field and it wasn't even close against
the New England Patriots so it's hard to
abandon ship there and then they were in
the UM and
on an anvil position of bidding against
themselves
in free agency so they gave them the
fifth-year option and they're gonna be
on the book for nineteen and a half
million that's not bad for him that's
not bad for him but they don't like that
so they cut it down yeah to ten for this
year so he got a two-year thirty six
million dollar deal basically and then
if he plays well in those two years
he'll see that third year so he went
toe-to-toe with Brady he listened can he
make plays certainly that this is the
point I think everybody have good
receivers this year the receivers are
injured they're better than you think I
know but see there's just you're going
by namesake that's all you think I would
argue with you they're there you know
yes I know Alan Robin these were proven
guys yes but still I just say this this
is the most talented team in football
like I told you then it's not even close
they were the best team in the sport if
you took the Patriot game against the
Jaguars and you took the best 22 guys in
the field I think you take 18 Jaguars I
mean you're gonna take 18 Jaguars you're
gonna take Brady Gronkowski McCourty and
maybe one of the guards for the New
England Patriots like Shaq Mason other
than that the rest of the team I'm
taking Jaguar players the game is
managed around Blake bortles and they do
everything to hide him I don't like
sitting here bagging on Blake bortles
I'm just trying to explain to people I
know Blake bortles hates me at this
point I'm sure of that and it's not
personal against them but I watch
football all the time you know that you
know so the game is caught they had two
timeouts of 55 seconds in the first half
okay they kneeled on the ball you know
the week before that they're beating the
Pittsburgh Steelers every because all
look Sims Blake bortles
you know it was 28 to 7 and he was 7 for
14 for 83 yards and no touchdowns and no
interceptions and the game was 28 to 7
so that just tells you the caliber of
the team they had you know they had to
they had a defense a touchdown and then
they had the interception by Myles Jack
that led to the Leonard fournette
touchdown then very next play that was
14 of their points so again I'm not
sitting here can they win with Blake
bortles can they go on and win the
Superbowl yes they can because they're
that talented but the thing I would say
is they have to manage the game around
him and if they had a really legit
throwing quarterback they would be
hands-down my pick to win the Super Bowl
what did the Vikings do
I think they're gonna go Kirk Cousins
like your like your intuition is telling
you yeah I really do I think that's good
I mean Kirk Cousins I think it's gonna
be jets jets or Vikings to me that's the
two teams that make sense
reason I say jets Jeremy Bates is the
offensive coordinator he was the quality
control coach in Tampa before Kyle
Shannon who was the quality code control
coach before Sean McVeigh under John
Gurdon said they were all there and the
system would be seamless for Kirk
Cousins to go to the Jets but I
understand Minnesota is a Superbowl
caliber team and they might want a guy
and they got the money to pay a Kirk
Cousins now you got a tattoo and Kyle
Shanahan got tattoos matching tattoos
right here go yes yes you did we did we
didn't lose in college we weren't like
spooning and like you know like hey
let's go get matching tattoos but who
brings up the conversation where you go
hey Kyle hey Chris what do you alright
so we were like there was five of us we
were like the first five freshmen on
campus and it was mean Kyle Shanahan
Bose gave rod Babers Montrell flowers
okay and we got there and of course
since we were the young guys we hung out
together all the time and the older
veterans started calling us the wood
there's a movie about four black guys
called the wood who always hang out
together right so I actually have never
seen the full movie I've only seen bits
and pieces but they call this the wood
so it kind of just kept on that was our
freshman ear and then our junior year
which time do I have seating sorry about
40 seconds okay we were embracing it and
we called ourselves the would like yeah
you guys want to go out into the club
with the wood tonight and do all that
and I was actually the first one that
got the tattoo you're sporting wood
right now I went out it's on my left
ankle yes that's their wood they're not
just Kyle's initials but my other
friend's initials too so is it the
smartest decision I ever made certainly
not but I did it and that's that's all
there is what did your dancing uh he
called me up because I paid with my
mom's credit card
and he said so what'd you do get a
tattoo or get your ears pierced and I
was like what are you talking about
Chris thanks for stopping by as always
thanks for having I appreciate it for
more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]